by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley and today
it might be a sad day because um
there are some rumors swirling online in
the metaverse that uh i've taken an l
and i have to be forthright with you i
have to be honest i have to come
clean i have to speak my mind in an
unfiltered manner so that you will trust
me
now and in the future
and i just want to provide full
transparency here
the haters have in fact
won say it ain't so mark
believe me casey i don't want to admit
this however
haters have been saying mark you're not
gonna do a full-length episode this week
because you're too busy doing all the
things that you're involved with and you
might have to cut it a little bit sure
you might have to not do a full hour or
near hour
at first my instinct was to deny this
and say
no way i'm doing three hours today
and then fill the rest of the episode
with
white noise and hopefully nobody would
notice but that's
something that i simply can't live with
i can't sleep at night knowing that i
attempted to deceive my listening
audience so
i'll come up front and just say it i
took an l today because i am going to
san diego laugh factory san diego where
are you at i'm going to be there with
the trash panda tour yes i am leaving in
a sec and we are pressed for time why
because oh was i out last night
at the one
press uh one championship press
conference right after work then went to
the improv taking pictures doing the
damn thing am i angry about that no did
i get up at 5am to go train somebody at
six yes i did
and those are the kind of decisions i
make that
perhaps leaves you pressed for time
perhaps
gives you sub-optimal sleep and sleep is
important however i find myself not
regretting those things because
i've conditioned myself to anticipate
how am i going to feel by the end of the
week let's say i go into san diego
you're in a different city maybe you
don't work out as hard as you want to or
take
a workout every day or do anything right
the difference between i took off a
couple days versus i haven't worked out
for five days right or getting through
the rest of the day
driving in a car knowing you didn't work
out this morning i just know that i feel
better even though there's a temporary
discomfort
waking up at 5 am when you pulled into
your parking spot at 12 pm i have the
screenshot to verify this casey he just
he rolled his eyes at me i don't know
why he's doing that
i think the assumption here is that i
got nine to ten hours of sleep that's
just not true now
this will be a temporary thing
i vow to come back next week and give a
four-hour podcast to make up for the
fact this podcast will only be four
minutes um
i i don't want to
feel like you haven't gotten your
money's worth for all the people who are
future subscribing to my patreon in your
head when that comes out um
don't feel like i'll ever shortchange
you or not give you the content that you
need so let's just jump right into it
what's up full
well this past weekend let me just tell
you about something real quick we were
in fort wayne indiana
brenda meets a comic who came from
indianapolis
and
that's like two and a half hours away
he goes oh i'm a struggling comic that's
didn't say i'm struggling with homicide
i'm a comic who
is looking for stage time been doing
about two years and guess what he says
you want to come do five minutes
tomorrow night he says yes now of course
this could have gone disastrously right
for everyone involved you bring a guy on
stage it's your show it's like oh he
bombs
sorry everybody
you're the guy who bombs oops sorry
everybody
maybe this isn't for me
so many ways that it could have gone
wrong however
i'm there i capture this moment on video
go out there have no idea i've never
seen this guy jacob kendall jacob
kendall 69.
why you got the 69 in there jacob i
don't know maybe
when you get a little more attention
change one of those numbers i think
could probably fix the issue here moving
forward but then again you are a
comedian 69 will never stop being funny
so
he gets on stage absolutely rips it i
get it on camera
and look
if he bombed i would have got that on
video too and i would have shown that to
all his friends and family and said hey
jacob
this isn't for you i'm putting you to
group chat with you your mom your
grandma and any surviving relatives just
to tell you that maybe working in the
steel mine the steel factory the coal
mine what have you
uh doing landscaping maybe that's
something more up your alley however
that wasn't the case he crushed it we
invited him back for the next day
he crushed it again and again and again
and i think it's just cool to see people
have an opportunity this is what life is
all about
giving people opportunity taking
opportunities recognizing them
focusing
doing your best making the best showing
of yourself he was prepared for that
moment he did have a tight five minutes
and i think that's analogous to a lot of
things
preparation meets opportunity is a
cliche
but it is true
people complain about opportunities
especially in l.a you know people like
i'm waiting for my big break or my
opportunity there's a mindset of like
i'm waiting you know not to say that
i've never been
somebody who buys into that mindset of
like waiting for an opportunity but
ultimately we all know
that creating that opportunity or being
prepared as much as you can be for the
moment an opportunity should arise
because you still have to perform on the
day
that's what life's all about brendan
cool on you for giving the guy an
opportunity
jacob very good on you for crushing it
hope to see you again
and check out his page give him a follow
give a shout out say what's up dude
heard you were funny in fort wayne get
out of fort wayne come to la asap
sue
you know i wanted to talk a little bit
about
the mind muscle connection in this
week's bro science academy
it's something i've been thinking a lot
as i've done more training sessions with
mike o'hearn
will
do things exercises that
are a little bit unconventional right
now
we start off lifting heavy with the
compound movements we start off doing
for example the other day we're doing
shoulders we do a behind the neck press
i go up to 195 mic goes up to 2 45
everything's slow controlled deliberate
two to three reps come to a complete
stop before you engage on the next rep
perfect form but still going heavy
merging those two things in what he
calls power bodybuilding
then we go into the auxiliaries and
i guess this is just something that
perhaps
as a beginner as somebody learning to
lift weights
the mind muscle connection idea it can
be overrated because you ask a
bodybuilder like what's the most
important thing mind muscle connection i
don't count reps i don't look at the
weight that's all bs to some degree
because ultimately you have to keep
track of what you're doing if you don't
care about the weights at all well how
can you progress how can you know what
you're doing and if you don't inherently
enjoy just lifting the weights
there's no enjoyment in it and you end
up just going through the motions
however
if you're not checking in with yourself
to say do i feel this movement in the
targeted area
then you're also not going to be making
any progress so
mike showed me a few moves that
i feel like for the first time for
example in my traps i gave a variation
the other day of
like a bent over
shrug with dumbbells we did another one
that was a behind the back shrug with a
barbell
where you're you have a relatively close
grip hip width grip
and you're pulling it up with your
elbows you ever shrugged this high
behind your back it looks like something
you shouldn't be able to do however you
can feel the contraction in your traps
and it ends up being like holy [ __ ] i'm
sore in places
that i've never been sore before uh he
had us do a lat pull down where you're
sitting imagine you're sitting in a lab
pull down then reverse it
so
you're facing backwards and you lay your
back down
where your knees would normally go under
i don't know if that makes sense but you
end up kind of like this and the things
behind you right and you
stick your
legs out and your butt
out so like
if you're pulling too hard too quick you
would actually pull yourself up right
so it takes away your ability to use any
momentum
and this contraction for example i'm
pulling it and it's like it's actually
kind of hard to get like
close to your chest it's a really
awkward contraction but if you pull into
that you feel it in your rear delt like
i've never felt before i don't really
even feel it
when i'm doing for example every rear
delt fly with a the machine the reverse
pec deck or a dumbbell
but in this particular instance it's
like oh damn
that works i've been feeling that and so
you ask mike and you go like where do
you come up with this stuff he'll
attribute it to
you know oh i learned this from arnold
or i learned this from lou ferrigno or
whatever but a lot of these things i'm
like i get the feeling you've personally
experimented and come up with certain
things
just through you're there for decades
you're there doing this thing
and you make little tweaks and see what
works and he's like yes that's true so i
decided to take that on
i have an issue in my pack and uh
basically
from my shoulder issue right pressing
doesn't quite contract the entire pec
muscle the way i want it to i have this
imbalance but i noticed
that when i do like a dumbbell pullover
i got this pump
under here in the pec minor right that
kind of gave my pec a volume that i have
in my stronger pack that i never had
here so i'm like how can i merge those
two and it was on my mind
like many problems are
when you're
you know
asking yourself something i feel like
people come up with creative solutions
to problems by posing the question and
then at some point it gets answered so
yes i'm building this all up just to say
i came up with a new exercise
i'm between two cable stacks
i didn't grab the handles right imagine
i'm like on my knees between these two
things right and if the line is here if
i'm pulling straight down and it's like
this i'm actually going behind that on
my knees
and pulling no handles just like those
the black ball pulling black balls into
myself right
so i'm going like this and i'm pulling
into myself right you see that oh and
you feel that contraction right there
i've never seen anybody do this but it's
predicated on the notion of i'm going
around and going where can i feel that
muscle contract from what angle from
what position and then replicating that
with the tools that i have now you can
all do that yourself but also
take any exercise that you do
and take that principle and go do i feel
it in the target muscle group is this
the proper range of motion is there more
tension at a certain spot like some
people do curls and it's like
the rest up here or you know in a bicep
curl that you're standing on
you can change the arc of the tension by
leaning forward a little bit by leaning
back right these are all things that i
do like set to set exercise to exercise
and it makes all the difference in the
world
you can easily cheat yourself or
convince yourself oh i'm doing something
i'm making this rep harder i'm keeping
constant tension or doing a full range
of motion even though you're taking the
tension off the muscle i mean like i'm
going up here then taking a second to
rest and coming back down that's just an
example from
bicep curls but one thing that mike
showed me we're doing front raises and
something as simple as front races right
that you assume
you know how to do everybody knows how
to do a front raise because you can just
look at it and go oh you go up to here
go up to here go up to here
and he goes what about coming higher
and it's like a hot duh right
when you come all the way up here first
of all a lot of people have mobility
issues where
you know
the sign of the healthy shoulder is can
you get your bicep past your ear a lot
of people can't
casey's like oh boom
yeah but you'll see a lot of this how
they test you know your mobility and for
example on my
on my bad shoulder it's just a little
bit off right so this is still a
difficult position and i want to create
tension in that difficult position with
not a lot of weight but maybe i'm
holding a 20 and instead of stopping
here i'm going up to here and
challenging myself to hold it in that
position
and that's also going to help on things
like my high inclines or whatever i
realize oh that's a weak position that i
need to work on
similar thing with any of the stuff that
you've looked at from
knees over toes guy where it's all about
putting yourself in a weaker position a
more vulnerable position that maybe you
injured yourself in extending that knee
you know
in a reference to the title of his
channel extending the knee over the toes
even though you're told not to do that
putting yourself in a compromised
vulnerable weak position and then
gradually strengthening up from there
right
so that's a principle that you can
always
lifting heavy weights with perfect form
is great but also do these things where
you drop the weight a lot and that's the
interesting
juxtaposition to use my favorite word of
all time
between working with a guy like mike you
go we're heavy we're doing heavy squats
heavy presses heavy things exercises to
lead off but then we go really light
with perfect form and make swap small
tweaks that amplify the tension that
you're feeling in the muscle
and maybe you should do that yourself oh
my goodness gracious
no casey because you were asking before
um
how am i going to make it through the
whole podcast
doing all the material i planned to do
but just shrunk down to what 38 39
minutes well the secret here today is
that i'm on kratom from happy hippo
herbals.com did i use promo code
thickboy to buy it no it was at the
office already but if i didn't work here
i would be using promo code thickboy3cs
at checkout to get 20 off for the rest
of my life and if you're following my
advice
you're gonna lead a long and happy one
okay so that's a lot of kratom go pick
it up now
okay our next segment is going to be oak
and stone clothing
got him no seriously am i even wearing a
shirt right now that's how comfortable
this thing is now i was at the one
championship press conference last night
getting compliments left and right like
are you a male model or you just wear
really nice clothes it fits your body
perfectly and i'm like well a little bit
of both okay
you've seen my instagram of course i'm a
male model and of course my exclusive
contract is with
oakenstoneclothing.com now this is hot
off the presses i just got this package
with this blue scoop neck shirt last
night i love the way it fits i love that
because my traps are so big it lets
those bad boys breathe a little bit and
it also lets my entire body breathe
because the fabric isn't so nice and so
even though it's summer outside
it's a moderate temperature fall
in my body go to
oakenstoneclothing.com right now and use
code hella h-e-l-l-a for 10 off oh and
by the time
this airs
tomorrow there's gonna be a big
sale actually so
ten percent off plus some even more
percentage off oh
i love oakenstone clothing but they're
just like 25 too expensive your prayers
have been answered
check it out shop now and support your
boy
so
with that being said a lot of people
have been asking me
i had a kid hit me up and sometimes i
don't like honestly you know
i'm dm'ing a 15 year old
a 15 year old boy with
questions about his deadlift and
honestly something like it i have a
pretty well calibrated troll
meter because kids will you know as i've
said before
it's about gratitude and entitlement
that's the metric that i'm usually
trying to gauge like are you coming at
me even with a a whiff of dickishness
that usually leads out to you're trying
to get information out of me or trying
to prank me or something like that i'm
pretty good about calling it out this
one i was on the fence about and he
seemed genuine but he was like
asking me a bunch of questions like how
do i deadlift how do i get girls i'm
like
is this serious
um because obviously if you know how to
deadlift you can get girl so i'm gonna
help you there and answer two questions
two birds with one stone
lift heavy get laid it's as simple as
that folks
he sends me a video of himself
deadlifting
is it the worst form of all time
no
but
he's using too much weight
right
there's thoracic bending there's no
abdominal stiffness a lot of people will
start off and they know the correct
position you can get yourself into a
correct athletic position
just for mimicking something visually
right you get into that like you know
flat back
nice angle to your waist into your knees
you get in there but then as soon as you
go to lift it immediately their back
arcs up they do the cap back they lose
all tension in their hamstrings
in their spine in their abdomen
and it's because simply they're using
too much weight right so i'd rather have
you you know or what i recommended to
him was like hey
cut the weight in half do ha whatever
you think your max is right now go to 50
or below show me what that looks like
with perfect form not just a perfect
starting position and let's work from
there and i'm gonna work with this kid
right
and i'm gonna send some videos but even
then it's like you know you can watch a
video and
maybe conceptualize it can you execute
it that's another thing without somebody
actually coaching you i'm gonna work
with him the second thing that i thought
was funny though that's the reason i'm
passing it on
is he goes uh how do you improve your
grip strength and i'm like grip strength
isn't your issue it's not as if you're
doing a perfect deadlift and all of a
sudden at the very end it's slipping out
of your hands you can grip the bar your
body just can't handle the weight
so i love stupid questions like that
because i get to feel smart
and of course that drives my entire
existence
pseudo-intellectualism i think they call
it but no seriously people do ask things
like i i find myself a lot going you're
focusing on the wrong thing
grip strength isn't the issue
you're asking me about grip strength
for
the purpose
of having a better deadlift but you need
a better deadlift in order to improve
your grip strength right that's i might
deadlift more with better form if you do
enough dead lifting
you get the popeye forearms
and if you eat your spinach
side note when i was a kid
i was really
obsessed with the notion that eating
spinach would give me giant muscles i
think we all were
right the most effective propaganda
campaign ever for spinach was
perpetrated by the popeye cartoons then
i get it in a can because my dad bought
it looks like disgusting green sludge
and i'm like you know what i think i'm
cool off muscles actually
i'll wait till i learn about steroids
once again big spinach
this is just another example big spinach
just manipulating how we see reality you
know
they want to make you think there's no
side effects to spinach
i'm not going to put this foreign plant
in my body
okay
so
you know there was actually the speaking
of the last michael i heard anything but
he got in a little spat with kenny kale
kenny caleb makes the living off like
he's gonna be like drama fitness
channels where he goes around like
calling people out for
not being naughty or asking them
difficult questions and i guess it does
provide like a valuable service in a
sense
of like you know there should be some
sort of check you should be scared of
somebody calling you out we can't all
play nice all the time you should be
asked difficult questions
normally he fares a lot better i guess
when he goes up against people and
calling him out like i remember the
thing he did with simeon panda where
it's like asked him if he's not mad he
was kind of in front of a panel
simeon
i want to say loses his mind but he just
loses his cool
he starts kind of yelling at kenny in
front of these people and he normally
seems like a pretty calm relaxed nice
guy no simian panda top you know
one in a billion genetics i mean the
guy's physically gifted his waist is
tiny his shoulders are insanely broad
you couldn't you know train that you
can't train those proportions
whether he's on steroids or not i really
don't know
but obviously he has a legitimacy just
as far as his shoulder to waist ratio
alone right
it's something you can't train and it
sort of looks like you know oh you're
lean and you have this crazy ratio it's
insane but anyway
he goes up to mike at a recent
at a fitness conference in vegas
and it was interesting to see and again
this is a hella rhetorical
segment it was interesting to see how
mike turned it on him
because kenny goes up and
asks him about you know are you have you
always been natty are you on steroids
are you on trt etc
and
mike kind of turns the tables on him and
goes
why is it that i've been stronger than
you since before puberty
candy ko is a big guy he's like six four
six five
i think his max bench is like 315 that
i've seen
so
some of these guys and i think a lot of
the people who call out
people on not being naughty or
constantly accusing others i've never
seen a guy with like a really amazing
physique doing this
there's another guy phileon who
he made his whole channel kind of like
[ __ ] on people and
calling out fake nannies etc
and it turns out like
he had some posts from way back in the
day he wanted to be a fitness influencer
he's like oh oh your first few posts
that you know you've since deleted or
archived are you hitting a squat and
like you know being like hit me up for
fitness advice and you wanted to go down
that road and realize maybe you didn't
have the genetics or the looks or the
charisma or whatever for that particular
thing which is fine
you know you can go down a path oh this
isn't for me and you know unless you
sort of like look like a model and have
amazing genetics and
you know
that's a parent at 18 years old maybe
it's not for you
but
it's an interesting correlation between
that and the sort of resentment that
might drive somebody to make their
entire youtube channel about calling
people out because your mindset becomes
well i can't do it so how could they
right when the truth is kenny can't
possibly be that disciplined he doesn't
have abs mike so mike
he goes lift up your shirt he makes uh
kenny show his
abs you know to everyone around and then
has his
wife who's in her mid-40s and recently
had a baby lift up her shirt and he's
like why is my 46 year old wife more
ripped than you she just had a baby
why is she stronger than you
right could this be a work ethic thing
could this be a diet thing could you
account for these disparities in uh ways
that aren't
anabolic related and this is true i've
played this out i've got to see it
because i've known people in high school
and college and at many points along the
way who've taken steroids
i've seen people thrive with it i've
seen people completely fail in it and
many of these people
are users and kenny has used sarms he's
done
steroids he's done like this tony huge
mass blast like he's taken a lot of
stuff and has experimented with a lot of
stuff i don't know what he takes now but
he's certainly not natural and i guess
the point is
at least on the flip side of like you
know you can't always tell visually if
somebody's on steroids but you certainly
can't tell if they're on steroids like
if somebody looks like they're not on
steroids that is not proof that they're
not on steroids because i've seen people
who you would never guess are on
steroids who are on a lot of steroids
not just like oh i dabbled in it it's
like
this person really thought
they were going to do a
you know a cycle and
become mr universe and it's just you
would never in a million years pick them
out of a lineup so
think about that and think about i want
you to watch this clip come back maybe
comment on it who won the exchange
because mike and i have a similar
mindset to like if you're going to come
to me and be rude or or do something
else all i have to do
in my case and i think we related on
this because we discussed the
interaction is like i'm going to point
out sort of basic facts of what you're
doing right look at what you're doing
you're coming to me accusing me
of being enhanced
meanwhile you're enhanced
and
my wife in her mid-40s looks better
and is stronger than you what does that
account for
right are there things outside of
uh you know anabolic use that can
explain these discrepancies
and for someone like michael hern
regardless of what you think about his
substance use
it's like several decades of extreme
consistency
casey
what's the most you've ever been
consistent for like you think of
yourself in terms of like a year i've
like trained really hard and done this
like wherever your best results come
from yeah probably during the pandemic
actually since i had the opportunity to
not focus on anything else i was just
like i didn't drink for like 90 days i
would wake up work out and then go skate
and i put out like four uh skate
sections during that time so that was
definitely like
obviously
i was able to only focus on that because
we were in a global [ __ ] pandemic but
given the opportunity that right that
would definitely be my longest most
disciplined time yeah and that's an
interesting
you know way to frame it because you go
it doesn't matter how you had the
opportunity to just focus on it the fact
is you were allowed to just focus on
this and look what you did right because
some people will
have that opportunity that same
opportunity and get fat also right
i did that for like a week and i'm like
i see where this is headed i need to
find a hill run i need to find a way to
work out does it involve the gym and i
also got really lean i also became super
disciplined with eating it is much
easier when you don't have other things
to focus on
now michael hearn's been making a living
as a fitness model for many years so
like that is has been his job however
professional bodybuilders you'll see
they get disgustingly fat in the off
season they don't take training that
seriously they're just not as committed
or disciplined and consistent they still
might look really good but mike's an
example of somebody who's just like
essentially a machine with regards to
diet consistency training wakes up every
day and does it and again as i've seen
i've witnessed it in person it's like
he achieves a level of sort of like
rep perfection
and deliberate execution of the things
that he's picturing that is pretty next
level
most people don't have an understanding
of what that would do to them even for
six months right like my fat friend who
i'm thinking of who took a steroid
cycling you'd have never you never know
it's like try eating clean for six
months earning perfectly where you never
do a single cheat meal
you never miss a workout you start
working out hard because you've been
half-assing it all these things
i guess what i'm coming
all the way back around to is try that
out i'm not saying don't accuse other
people doing steroids because it shows
your resentment it's true but
give yourself a time frame to be
consistent in
see what can happen in a month two
months three months
a year
two years of actual consistency
if not 100 95
you know you would be shocked at what
you can do
amazing things
is that it for my am i out of time to do
this serious stuff because guess what we
can get on to some this is why we can't
have nice gyms
yay
this girl okay so i'm playing this
little video here
this is why we can't have nice gyms if
you've ever noticed cultural differences
in the aesthetic that women sort of
aspire to you go to brazil
the breasts look different right the
breast implants look different there's a
different aesthetic they do tan lines
they like all these little things are
like brazilian specific and i remember
seeing a brazilian playboy for the first
time at whatever age i'm like oh my god
like
their idea of you know the beauty
standards of the western whatever every
country has different beauty standards
i'd never seen a girl in a playboy with
thick thighs before this is like in the
90s right every girl in brazil who wants
to be an influencer or a hot chick
they want this like big quad big ass
look not just the big ass right they
want an actual muscular
quad hamstring calf it's almost like a
stubby look that they're going for do
you know what i'm talking about casey
i'm not crazy right no you see this
and these girls all seemingly trained
i've seen this girl
yeah vivi is her name vivi winkler
she just pushes these girls to the
absolute limit like she does like drop
sets and you know uh like pushes like he
does assisted reps is always right there
like pushing on this thing it's super
intense leg training so it's like you
know don't ever tell me your legs won't
grow if you're not doing something you
can make them grow it's just like raise
the volume raise the intensity go to
your puke doing drop sets your legs can
handle a lot it's just so physically
painful
to both your cardiovascular system and
your musculature that most people pass
out
now when i look at this girl she's very
hands-on very touchy-feely i have to
assume she's a lesbian and i have to
also then assume this is the best job on
the planet for her uh training brazil's
hottest women and touching their legs
and butts all day so
if there's a job application vivi i
would love to be your assistant and move
to brazil learn to portuguese
i can i can follow up with the gauge
just give me the duo lingo okay
now this guy this guy's hilarious
uh skyler skyler scotch in his name
he's
he said reasons why you shouldn't train
legs stop working your
legs girls think big legs are disgusting
with legs like these i fornicate all the
time reason number three i'm not a
[ __ ] beta are you skipping lines bro
i am you can't [ __ ] peer pressure me
john and if you want to join the
movement hit that plus button
i love this dude it's like using that
like tick-tock instructional video sort
of format like here's three things
shut the [ __ ] up wow but
this guy loved it with a straight face
he almost had me he's like you can't put
muscle on your upper body and lower body
at the same time i'm like wait is that
true
am i learning something today okay this
is why you should never lift dumbbells
okay
okay kicks it up comes down
what the ah
now what is that casey is that an arm
breaker is that an elbow dislocation i
think it's a dislocation yeah and you
know what honestly the weights looked a
little too heavy for him right it's like
when you're that weak and that fragile
maybe just drop the weight a little bit
get a deeper stretch there's some let's
look at it one more time
and let's all puke together
as we watch this guy
ruin his life uh-huh
yeah there's something about where i'm
like he just you can't control it that's
really the thing regardless of how heavy
the weight is if you can't control the
weight
don't lift it and don't have sex with
her okay
if you're a male stripper and she's over
300 pounds and she jumps onto you don't
bring her on stage that's the real thing
if you're a male stripper don't bring
that 300 pound woman on stage
it's a setup to failure this guy is also
one of my favorite bapito
oh [ __ ] in the most important step
you're going to explain how she used to
smell like
if you know what i mean you just go like
follow me
i love that because it's like you know
the most effective smelling salt of all
time is the perfume of your
ex-girlfriend
oh it makes sense though it's silly but
it's like well
that could be a motivation that could
get you through the gym you know
oh she smells like that
when you find out girls don't actually
like muscles
he goes in the leg press he takes out
the safety and then takes his legs off
and i'm going how did he film that
without the leg press just destroying
him oh i guess oh my god this is a
suicide video we just played casey
quick go into the next cut this out
we can't we can't show
live suicide tick tocks i don't know who
edited it together but you're sick for
doing that okay
next one we got is oh this guy's crew
you know this this is my favorite genre
of gym videos is like the cot in the
wild what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
right he's just like got on his lap and
he's like going back and forth like it's
some sort of uh
you know geriatric white mating dance
what is he thinking what is he doing
these are the people again that i want
to go up an interview and go what do you
think you're doing right because you
could do whatever you want and he's not
hurting anybody however i do get angry
as we've discussed before things in the
gym i seem to have a heightened anger
response in the gym oh by the way i have
the story
i realized i was listening to the
podcast before i'm like oh i went
started this story
where this guy i had 315 on my back and
i'm working out with somebody else and
this guy who i say hi to sometimes is
like
one more as i'm doing deep squats with
315. it's a heavyweight but i'm still
warming up with it
and i look over at him i'm like oh
should i do one more he's like yeah and
so i do one more and just out of spite i
like went to 15 or something like that
like exhausted you know but i just kept
going like all the way down i should go
should i do one more
should i do one more should i do one
more like that's how passive aggressive
is that you know like to spike this guy
you know i did a set of 15 when i was
only planning on doing a warm-up set of
five
315 deep squats
but
again it was a fun way for me to express
that frustration of like don't ever
talk to somebody
with 300 pounds anywhere on their body
that they're supporting you know don't
in the middle of a deadlift i'm like one
more i didn't you don't know how many
sets i'm doing you know how many reps
i'm doing you don't know what my max is
you know nothing about me and you're not
inspirational to me you're some 23 year
old kid weighs 170 pounds
don't ever look me in my eye again
now on the next set this is really where
it comes you know i got over that right
do a little joke and clearly you got
over clearly look obviously i've
compartmentalized this and let it go i
don't even care about it anymore why
would you say that
casey is the one who brought it up
actually
um on the next set i go up to 365.
now is this partially my fault yes but
i'm extra angry because i know it's my
fault and i but i want to blame him
right and let's let's do a
metapsychological evaluation of what's
happening here i have 365 in my back and
i'm going for like a set of five now
because i took the warm-up set and did
it set to failure now i'm too tired to
do this complete set or i'm at least
more exhausted than i would have been uh
if i was a rational human but i had 365
in my back i go deep for one and then
two and then this kid over here is right
next to me on the smooth machine
he talks to someone else and i think
he's talking to me and i like go to turn
like i wanted to be like oh he's talking
to somebody else so i come back and i go
for another rep really quick to cover my
embarrassment
and i'm just slightly off right i lean
forward a little bit you lose focus
because squats it's like you gotta you
know go through your mental checklist
take the big breath and come down
balance so i came down with this slight
forward lean
and i am
very cautious
and good at bailing like knowing like
the instant that like i get caught
forward i'm like i don't want to be
stuck like you know trying to catch it
and throwing out my back so when i go oh
i might you know not be able to come out
of that i just throw it back but again i
wasn't on a platform it's just like the
dead second floor you know
no padding it's like asphalt basically
the the consistency on the ground so i
had to dump 365 from you know
almost six feet up in the air
that's okay
um clearly as casey said and pointed out
i'm over it right it's not even
something i think about if uh casey
wouldn't say wait mark make sure to talk
about the story from last week you left
off you left all of us hanging
but less than you guys don't talk to
people while they're working out and
you're not with them nobody needs your
motivation
right what if you just throw headphones
on
oh good well i was with another person i
was already with a workout partner it's
like if anybody and that's a good point
i would um because that's my thing if i
need people around me to shut the [ __ ]
up i just put on correct 100
and so that was but it's also like hey
if i have a workout partner don't you
think he'd be the one saying one more
you know if anybody but i don't even do
that it's like i'm going to let you go
to failure then i'm gonna one more like
yelling at me isn't gonna make me bench
press more
is this gonna make me realize you're a
mean person
okay
and oh we have another one
i like this one i thought we had it last
week i'm finding all the ones i thought
we're gonna do last week that i actually
put in the oakenstone podcast available
now on all platforms so we turn the
sound onto this one so this guy
deadlifts
and this is totally normal by the way a
guy to deadlift
and you drop it he's not like slamming
it extra hard but guess what everything
in the gym is already loud weights
clanking is loud the music is loud
that's what i was like oh you don't want
to drop the weight on the ground listen
to this shitty music that's playing over
the loudspeakers bombarding my ears but
one little clankity clank is too much
and so this woman is like off in the
corner like you need to stop deadlifting
it's really annoying and i'm always
doing a zumba class last week you guys
kept dropping the weights like oh your
zumba class wasn't louder than the three
second you know deadlift that these guys
are doing not even three seconds
three milliseconds
and you know
what i decided casey we're gonna end
this
right here we're gonna do a
sketch world premiere okay by the time
this episode airs
uh
and you've had a chance to listen to the
whole thing all 15 minutes of this
podcast
this is going to be the end and then
when the first person says hahaha that
was the funniest thing i've ever seen
then i'll post it to instagram okay okay
so what are we looking at right now it's
a video i took this morning and i'm
going to teach you how to execute the
perfect loud spread can we play it
a lot of people been asking me mark
what's the secret to a perfect lat
spread well there's really only one
secret be under 15 body fat because if
you ain't it's not a lot spread it's
just a fat spread stay lean
you hear that it's not a lat spread it's
just a fat spread so you're gonna
determine right now whether or not
i am 15 body fat i want you to comment
below
is this a lat spread or is it just a fat
spread